[Music]
Olivia Munn you know it's been about
five months since she broke up with her
boyfriend I'm Aaron Rodgers the
quarterback of the Green Bay Packers
well fans went kind of crazy on social
media when she posted a picture with her
friend who was wearing a Minnesota
Vikings hat they thought it was a dig at
her ex but Olivia had the perfect clap
back I didn't know that I wasn't allowed
to have friends who had boil tease the
other team but now that I know I'm
putting a mandate out there that anybody
in my life
can only wear a green and gold yes
Olivia is fierce in real life and in the
movie no this is your first time playing
someone's mom like a badass mom well
thank you the 37 year old star went
full-on tiger mom when she gave pal
Mindy Kaling this housewarming gift
someone comes up on you and you're like
is that real do you really have those i
well yeah that was mine from home their
stunt blasters it's a 950 thousand volts
of a stun gun I haven't been every room
in my house so don't come up on me at my
house if you just tap you you're gonna
die hundred fifty thousand like oh do
not blow up in the crib don't get
feelings hurt and more you're gonna get
a lot of hurt
[Music]
you